et au bout du fil jacqueline moreau elle
est en bretagne
c'est le premier visage qu'on a vu de ce
mouvement de mobilisation des gilets
jaunes un bon soir dans l'amour ou merci
d'être avec nous je sais que vous avez
une journée très occupée
vous étiez de cette rencontre je crois
avec le premier ministre edouard
philippe
hier vous êtes retourné chez vous en
bretagne j'appellerai au public peut
être que c'est votre coup de gueule à
vous il ya quelques semaines
interpellant macron le président macron
qui est un peu là aussi toute la sphère
est ce que vous aviez anticipé une telle
mobilisation suite ravoir votre
dénonciation votre coup de gueule alors
bonjour merci de me recevoir tout
d'abord non bien sûr que jamais j'aurais
pu imaginer qu'un coup de gueule posté
sur facebook se retrouve à produire un
mouvement comme ça d'ailleurs quand j'ai
posté ce coup de gueule je n'étais même
pas au courant que quelqu'un d'autre
avait organisé le rassemblement du 17
novembre
donc c'est des concours de circonstance
des synchronicité qui se sont produites
pour arriver à ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui
d'après vous est-ce que la rencontre
d'hier vous donne de l'espoir que le
gouvernement entende vos revendications
au certaines de vos revendications
alors donc hier soir
on a été ça a été assez compliqué parce
que on y est allés au culot un petit peu
en quelque sorte nous on fait partie du
groupe des gilets jaunes libre parce que
faut voir aussi que au sein des gilets
jaunes ya plusieurs groupes qui se sont
constitués moi je suis considéré comme
on fait pas faisant parti des modérés et
qui veulent des résolutions constructive
à ce conflit et donc on y est allés au
culot on s'est présenté devant matignon
et on a dit maintenant on va être reçue
alors commis avait réunion crise à
matignon toute la journée hier ils nous
ont reçus quand même à 20h15 puisque le
premier ministre avait dit que sa porte
était ouverte pour les gilet jaune
donc il nous a reçus on a passé une
heure et demie en sa compagnie ou le
débat a été très constructif on a plus
fait un constat qu autre chose et où il
a entendu toutes nos revendications une
à une
maintenant la balle est dans le camp du
président de la république puisque tout
où lui a été remonté c'était la promesse
qu'il nous a faite que le premier
ministre nous a fait de remonter les
informations au président est
aujourd'hui et bien selon le degré de ce
qui va se passer de ce qui est en train
de se passer à paris aujourd'hui et
après l'allocution du président macron
pendant qu'on annonce pour mardi matin
je pense que oui voila je pense que tout
ça va déterminer la suite du mouvement
est-ce que les débordements
d'aujourd'hui sur paris particulièrement
parce que ce sont les images très
éloquente que l'on voit est désolant par
ailleurs depuis le début de l'après midi
est ce que ces débordements nuisent à
votre qu aux abords revendications selon
vous malgré les appels à l'apaisement
que vous lancez sûr bien sûr que ça nuit
ça discrédite tout le mouvement
obligatoirement moi j'ai jamais appelé
aller sur paris parce que je considère
qu'elle est saccagée ça ne fera
certainement pas avancer les affaires de
la france
maintenant il ya des gens qui ont quand
même voulu y aller parce que pas
forcément paris c'est symbolique mais
moi quand je vois qu'on saccage l'arc de
triomphe contre un face à face elle j'ai
mal au coeur
quoi de voir ça
donc il faut que toutes ces personnes
qui sont là bas ne se laisse pas
embringué par les casseurs parce que
c'est très très compliqué c'est un
mouvement
la plupart du temps c'est pas déclarés
il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas de chef
donc à qui s'adresser pour les forces de
l'ordre françaises c'est un imbroglio
incroyable donc on est on est dans une
période très très compliqué de
l'histoire de france la même pas une et
qui peuvent penser que c'est cette
violence de semaine en semaine qui s'est
exprimée à travers les casseurs qui a
mobilisé le gouvernement qu'il a fait
agir ou plutôt réagir à la situation de
désordre mais le problème c'est que ce
qu'il y à deux pas normal c'est qu'on
doive en arriver à de la violence pour
être entendu le gouvernement français de
toute façon a trop attendu ça fait plus
d'un mois que ça dure ici un il savait
même avant le 17 novembre que la mobilit
que la mobilisation allait être forte
mais je pense qu'ils se sont pas
attendus à ça et le fait de ne pas avoir
répondu tout de suite ça fait monter
degré de colère à des niveaux mais
aujourd'hui qu'ils ne sont plus
maîtrisable quand même donc paraître
gouvernement et ce n'est plus
maîtrisable ni par le gouvernement ni
par les partis politiques français parce
qu'on les entend pas du tout ils savent
plus comment se raccrocher aux branches
les syndicats c'est pareil et le
mouvement est en train d'échapper au
gilet jaune eux mêmes alors comment
entrevoyez vous la suite des événements
vous avez dit tout à l'heure
selon ce qui se passe aujourd'hui on
verra la suite pour de la mobilisation
qu'est-ce que vous anticipez à partir de
maintenant qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir
de cette journée d'aujourd'hui pour que
votre cause reste légitime selon vous
est ce qu'il faut retenir c'est que ce
qu'on voit actuellement à la télé c'est
ça fait pas partie des revendications
des gilets jaunes
le problème voilà ce qu'on voit ce sont
les casseurs et les casseurs sont
capables d'embringuer un gilet jaune qui
étaient pacifiques le matin et qui se
retrouvent casseurs casseurs le soir
donc il faut faut dissocier
et en fait les gilet jaune de ces
casseurs le problème c'est que l'image
elle est ternie obligatoirement ça peut
pas en être autrement
donc selon comment est gérée la journée
d'aujourd'hui par le gouvernement
français par monsieur k spanair et selon
les les revendiquer fallait l'allocution
de monsieur macron tout ça va être
déterminant pour la suite
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui vous savez on
est rendu à un point où elle la
situation a tellement pourri que on
dirait aux gens demain vous avez 500
euros de plus par mois
eh bien je sais même pas si il
arrêterait vous personnellement quelle
est votre situation est ce qu'elle est
ce qu'elle est pertinent parce qu'on
doit la connaître pour comprendre ce que
vous revendiquez à moi par exemple je
vis avec moins de 900 euros par mois
voilà et donc je comprends très bien
quand les gens me disent et m'envoient
des centaines de milliers de messages
pour me dire ah oui moi je vis avec 700
et avec ça on vit pas en france c'est
très très cher de vivre en france
aujourd'hui on est assassiné par les
taxes et les impôts donc en fait on ne
sort le matin que pour aller chercher de
la pitance pour l'état français
donc et et nous on peut on ne peut plus
remplir nos frigos
on peut plus mettre de l'essence donc on
se demande ce que veut l'état en fait
au bout du compte ils veulent qu'on
reste chez nous ou alors il ya une
stratégie d'appauvrissement de la
population qui est en route et on arrive
qu elles arrêtées donc c'était
obligatoire que ça allait péter comme on
dit que le mouvement allait qu'un
mouvement comme ça allait se produire
le seul la seule chose c'est qu'ils
n'ont pas appréhender déjà avec
suffisamment de sérieux dès le départ et
qu'aujourd'hui et bien on a un véritable
tsunami et il va falloir attendre que la
vague et bâtons ben et que tout ça
s'apaise et mais combien de temps ça va
prendre c'est là là
le gros point d'interrogation moi je
comprends que vous attendez le discours
de maths du président macron mardi oui
pour plusieurs d'entre vous même s'il ya
plusieurs groupes déjà légion ne vous
avait pas vraiment de leader de porte
parole officiel mais plusieurs répète
pour qu'on comprenne bien que le retour
de l'impôt sur la fortune
ces mesures d'apaisement ce serait une
mesure en tout cas peut-être juste un
symbole mais qui sera un commencement
exactement parce que quand le président
macron est arrivée la première chose
qu'il a fait c'est supprimer cet impôt
alors après on c'est un autre débat de
penser qu'il est juste ou pas ou qu'il
fallait il a voulu supprimer pour que la
théorie du ruissellement se produise et
que l'argent qu'on prenait à ces
personnes soient réinvestis en france
seulement ça n'a pas été le cas
donc on a une évasion fiscale qui est
monstrueuse on est à plus de 100
milliards d'euros en france
d'évasion fiscale et on ne s'occupe pas
de ça par contre on continue à taxer les
gens qui n'ont pas d'argent donc c'est
obligatoire que ça devait en arriver là
maintenant si le président macron nous
annonce mardi qu'il rétablit sf bien sûr
ça réglera pas les problèmes de la
france
mais symboliquement ça je pense que ça
pourrait imposer à apaiser beaucoup de
deux personnes et est le deuxième
paramètre ça serait de peut-être annoncé
une augmentation du smic quoi parce que
les gens ils arrivent pour vivre vous le
900 euros c'est le smic ou c'est la
retraite
ah non non moi pas du tout moi je suis
une une indépendante je suis en auto
entreprise
donc j'ai même pas accès au smic je n'ai
pas accès mais moi je m'en fous de ma
situation vous savez tant pis tant pis
j'ai au moins pousser l'alertent j'ai
lancé l' alerte
maintenant ça a permis quand même de
faut voir le côté positif aussi du
conflit
ça a permis de libérer la parole des
gens parce qu'en france c'est tabou de
parler d'argent
personne ne parle de son salaire ici
c'est tabou alors main depuis ce
mouvement les gens sont sortis dans la
rue pour dire eh bien oui moi je gagne
tant abattoirs à moi
1 bat finalement on est dedans on est
dans le même dans la même merde hein
excusez moi du mot mais voilà et ça a
libéré la parole des gens donc c'est
quand on libère la parole ça soulage et
c'est ça qui est positif dans le
mouvement les gens se sont rencontrés
ils sont sortis de leur zone de confort
ils sont on a fait des rencontres
incroyables avec des gens qu'on n'aurait
jamais vu s'il n'y avait pas eu ce
mouvement là donc maintenant on en est
passé du côté positif et on atterrit
dans le côté négatif parce que ça n'a
que trop duré et donc ça va se terminer
comment elle a vraiment ça m'a fait
souffler ou continuer jeu honnêtement
honnêtement c'est très très compliqué de
dire comment ça va se terminer
aujourd'hui les gens sont on n'arrive
plus à maîtriser les gens quoi sur un
rond-point vous savez qu on and on est
champion du monde des ronds-points en
france on a une sur chaque rond point on
a une représentation de l'assemblée
nationale ça va de l'extrême droite par
le centre par le ps par la gauche et les
l'extrême gauche dont plus personne ne
s'entend
et c'est très très grave parce qu'on
n'arrive pas moi je fais partie des
personnes qui pensent qu'il faut
construire il faut transformer ce
mouvement dans de la construction
positif pour le pays mais les gens
n'arrivent plus à le comprendre
est-ce qui est ce que les intervenants
semaine dernière et avant une prochaine
étape pour vous c'est d'essayer de vous
organiser à pour avoir des
interlocuteurs avoir ne serait-ce qu'un
des services d'ordre et les manifs
continue est ce que c'est une c'est
illusoire de ce que de poser la question
en fait alors au tout départ chaque
chaque groupe qui s'était constitué pour
pour sortir le 17 novembre il y avait
des services d'ordre
ça s'est super bien passé mais là le
problème c'est que ça s'est radicalisée
et donc ceux qui sont radicalisées le
service d'ordre
ils sont fous tu as donc c'est très très
compliqué même pour pour nos services
d'ordre nationaux je vais dire police et
gendarmerie c'est ingérable
parce que les gens en plus sont
extrêmement mobiles ils sont capables
d'être 200 sur une place en un quart de
seconde
ça change de place et il se retrouve un
kilomètre plus loin
et ils remettent ça quoi donc c'est
ingérable s'est disséminé c'est des
points
il y en a partout enfin on est dans une
situation très compliquée la très bien
jacqueline moreau je rappelle que vous
êtes un des visages de cette
mobilisation des gilets jaunes vous avez
posté vous avez mis un message sur
facebook il ya quelques semaines et
c'est des millions et des millions de
vues maintenant c'est trop bien combien
de millions de vues savez vous j'ai
regardé c'est à 6 millions 300 mille 6
million trois cent mille 2 ans et ça
c'est que facebook c'est que facebook
parce que du coup elle et s'est rendu
sur youtube donc ça c'est exponentiel
après mais bon après je dirais c'est
significatif sur le nombre évidemment
parce que les gens ils ont liké comme
comme on dit mais ce qui est
significatif là c'est vraiment le nombre
de personnes qui avaient dans la rue et
ceux qui sont prêts à en découdre
il y en a qui sont prêts à en découdre
avec la démocratie française et c'est
très très grave
on a vu tout à l'heure des sur les
champs-elysées ou à proximité des jeux
les gens qui s'interposaient entre des
casseurs et pour ne serait ce que pour
protéger une vitrine de banque là on a
vu ça tout à l'heure
oui oui bah oui parce que dans la grande
majorité les gilets jaunes ils sont
pacifiques
mais le problème c'est que aller contre
une bande de casseurs les casseurs sont
organisées ce sont des mecs qui ne font
que de la guérilla urbaine
ils ne font que ça il se mêle à
n'importe quelle manifestation pour
casser donc ça peut devenir
potentiellement ultra violent c'est pour
ça que vous voyez les chars de la
gendarmerie à paris en ce moment ça
c'est ça dégénère c'est dingue quoi
jacqueline moreau depuis la bretagne où
vous êtes rentré cette nuit après avoir
rencontré le premier ministre edward
fait des pierres soir merci d'avoir
partagé pour réflexion avec nous et vos
revendications aussi pont
on attend bien sûr le discours du
président macron ce mardi alors merci à
vous merci à vous